[Music]
this video has been made possible by
brilliant a problem-solving based
website and app with a Hands-On approach
improve your stem skills while having a
great time learning at brilliant.org
forward slash visualpolitik en more on
this in a bit
[Music]
North Korea is back to its old tricks
[Music]
North Korea fires ballistic missile over
Japan projectiles 4 600 kilometer flight
potentially puts U.S territory of Guam
within pyongyang's range within less
than a month the old-fashioned communist
country of juche ideology has decided to
resume massive testing of its ballistic
missile program by firing missiles over
Japan and even more tauntingly south of
the South Korean Maritime border for the
first time in history what's more North
Korea has launched more than 20 missiles
in a single day representing one of the
biggest escalations which happened to
coincide with the massive Vigilant storm
joint drill between South Korea and the
US involving over 240 aircraft we can
even say that the love affair that arose
after the summit between Kim Jong-un
Trump and former South Korean president
moon jae-in has definitely come to an
end of course this is not the first time
Pyongyang has conducted a very
provocative tests what has happened over
the last month is definitely on the next
level to give you an example in 2017 the
North Korean regime also launched two
ballistic missiles that flew over Japan
and triggered missile alarms and alerts
to evacuate to bomb shelter those of you
who are part of our patreon community
surely already know some details about
the North Korean ballistic launch over
Japan basically because we told you
about it in our bulletin the weekly
snapshot but for those of you who are
not yet part of visualpolitics patreon
community let me summarize
on the 3rd of October 2022 Pyongyang
decided to launch an intermediate range
missile believed to be one of the Hua
song 12 type into the Pacific Ocean
beyond the military issue the fact is
that the launch over Japan and the
missile which landed in South Korean
Waters had above all a political reading
with it Kim Jong-un made it clear that
the time for dialogue was over and that
he is now ready to return his country to
a kind of military autarky known as the
songun doctrine that is the military
comes first this is a major Game Changer
of course the North Koreans will lose
out again because they will suffer a new
setback in life but the return of the
song and Doctrine also marks the return
of the policy of direct and permanent
confrontation with South Korea Japan and
the United States
in addition the latest ballistic test
over Japan had somewhat different
characteristics than usual this time the
launch was much more horizontal and at a
lower altitude specifically and
according to data confirmed by South
Korea the North Korean missile launched
on 3rd of October flew a horizontal
distance of 4 600 kilometers or 2858
miles exceeded 950 kilometers that's 590
miles in altitude and reached a speed of
Mach 17 that is 17 times the speed of
sound and while it's unclear what speed
it could register in real war conditions
and loaded with the weight of explosive
Warheads the test data puts it close to
becoming a Hypersonic weapon
[Music]
[Applause]
in addition for the first time North
Korea has demonstrated Beyond any doubt
that they would be capable of attacking
the island of Guam which belongs to the
United States of America
and take note because this island is a
key place for the military projection of
the U.S Army in the asia-pacific region
large quantities of military equipment
are stationed on Guam and it is even
believed that it could Harbor nuclear
weapons and now it is in pyongyang's
crosshairs because never before has the
North Korean regime successfully
launched a ballistic missile so far and
that has caused us to ask a few
questions how advanced is the North
Korean ballistic program really what
capabilities would it really have in the
event of a war what change does this new
capability mean for the balance of power
in the region well we're going to take a
look at that right now but before we
continue whether you're trying to
develop your professional skills or
broaden your understanding of the world
we recommend checking out today's
sponsor brilliant brilliant is a
problem-solving based website and app
with a Hands-On approach that's a better
way to learn they've got over 70
interactive courses in maths science and
computer science and it doesn't matter
whether you're a student looking to get
ahead or a professional keen on building
new skills you have to check out
brilliant it's excellent maybe you've
always wanted to learn about algebra
well stay tuned because they have just
released a new course introduction to
algebra where you'll be able to explore
the twin pillars of algebraic thinking
equations and graphs brilliant will help
you unpack algebra's main ideas and
develop a powerful perspective for
solving its essential problems there's
loads of great stuff on their platform
which include daily challenges which are
a great Flex to our great matter of
every day so don't wait any longer and
let brilliant help you master even
complex technical subjects by clicking
on the link below you'll get started for
free and hurry because the first 200
people get 20 off an annual premium
subscription
[Music]
high flying deterrence
[Music]
North Korea or rather Kim jong-un's
regime is absolutely clear about one
thing they do not want to become the new
Libya in fact it is not uncommon for him
to hold up to the latter country as an
example of the mistake that abandoning
the nuclear program can entail Libya did
so in 2003 and by 2011 Gaddafi was dead
naturally King Jong-Un does not want to
suffer the same fate and the truth is
that this approach is entirely logical
if you are an unscrupulous dictator and
you don't give a damn about people's
lives their nuclear weapons are your
best life insurance in pyongyang's
offices behind closed doors it is very
clear to them that their rudimentary
combat forces compete in different
galaxies from those of South Korea let
alone the United States the
technological evolution of recent
decades has left them completely out of
the game precisely for this reason for
more than 20 years North Korea's defense
plans have only taken into account one
premise to increase the cost of a
foreign military intervention in the
country in other words it is not a
matter of being able to repel an attack
but of the cost being so high that no
one is willing to pay that price it is
the policy of deterrence taking to its
highest level and that is exactly where
nuclear weapons and ballistic missiles
fit in and the further those weapons can
go the greater their deterrent
capability and therefore their life
insurance
the Kims wants to make their nuclear
weapons capable of directly attacking
the United States in their view this
would strengthen their political clout
and make them completely Untouchable and
that is why once nuclear weapons have
been developed the next step in the
whole military strategy is precisely the
development of an effective ballistic
missile system and also the development
of shorter range and more accurate
missiles capable of reaching U.S bases
in Okinawa Hawaii and one
in this way the North Koreans ensure
that a possible regime change does not
enter into Washington's plans especially
if they are unpredictable irritable and
impulsive with all that force it would
be something similar to a rabid dog
strategy to put it simply don't come
closer I will bite yes in a way I think
that would be a good way to sum up
pyongyang's perverse game but okay this
is all quite logical and nothing new but
the question I'm sure many of you are
asking is but let's see Josh North Korea
is a very poor and technologically a
very backward country how on Earth is it
possible that it has managed to develop
such Advanced nuclear weapons and
missiles flying 4 600 kilometers and
reaching Max 17 is not exactly Child's
Play well the fact is that North Korea
is a very poor country but it is also a
country with a single obsession
so it is estimated that the government
allocates between 20 and 30 percent of
all national resources to the military
every year and it is the only country in
the world in that range in other words
North Korean production basically feeds
two things subsistence and Military
according to South Korean estimates
we're talking about an annual investment
in its armed forces of between 7 and 11
billion dollars but of course there are
several things to take into account here
spending on salaries is minuscule to
give you an idea the four star generals
receive somewhere between a little more
than one thousand dollars a month from
the government Corrupt Practices aside
and if we're talking about the
professional troops It is believed that
salaries range between ten dollars and
forty dollars a month and those in
compulsory military service do not even
reach that someone like other armies
let's just say that Manpower is a much
smaller consumption of resources this
allows them to free up a large part of
their available resources for their two
absolute priority objectives border
defenses and strategic armaments that is
nuclear bombs and ballistic missiles in
North Korea you're not going to see
Modern Combat Weaponry Advanced
artillery high-tech tanks or a large
combat air fleet they have understood
perfectly well that in all those fields
they cannot compete
on the other hand surprising as it may
seem to you the truth is that it is
incredibly cheap to develop nuclear
weapons the reason more countries do not
have this Weaponry is largely because of
the commitment to non-proliferation and
not due to cost or technology
[Music]
let me explain according to South Korean
government estimates made in 2016 the
North Korean nuclear weapons program may
have cost between 1.1 billion and 3.2
billion dollars and yes that figure may
have increased somewhat by 2022 but
roughly speaking it's not going to
amount to much more than that so even a
country as poor as North Korea can
afford it what's more South Korean and
ubis intelligence believe that both the
ballistic and nuclear programs have been
largely financed by hackers
cryptocurrencies and illegal trafficking
[Applause]
[Music]
for example it is known and it is even
reported by the United Nations that in
order to obtain foreign currency in
recent years the North Korean regime has
systematized its operations of smuggling
drug trafficking and the sale of
military equipment to poor countries
countries under sanctions and
paramilitary groups this is an issue
that we talked about some time ago here
on visualpolitik and that explains to a
large extent why economic sanctions have
not been able to stop the development of
these programs in fact it is relatively
well known that the North Koreans have
even created clandestine arms production
networks in various parts of Africa to
supply disreputable Warlords and
governments North Korea's surprising
lucrative relationship with Africa
nambia had contracted with the North
Korean company called Man City overseas
projects to build a Munitions Factory as
well as a new military academy
filmmaker spends 10 years secretly
recording North Korea's Shady dealings
leveraging hidden cameras the film
shares illegal triangle trade deals to
smuggle Russian oil into the dprk North
Korea Underground arms factories on a
private Ugandan Island and sales
meetings on North Koreans weapons
initially intended for Syria and this is
examples of all these activities but
beyond the economic issues let's move on
to what you probably most want to know
about what on Earth is it like and what
does the North Korean ballistic program
entail well let's take a look
[Music]
one all risk policy
the facts beat for themselves since it
launched its ballistic technology
development program back in the late
1980s and early 1990s North Korea has
made significant progress and not
surprisingly it has based its first
missiles on Soviet technology
[Music]
the vast majority of North Korean
short-range missiles are improved
developments of those known in NATO
nomenclature as scuds along these lines
the first North Korean missile was
developed from the Soviet r-17 Elbrus or
scud B so both the liquid propellant
engines and the guidance system of
short-range missiles are derived from
Russian technology this is for example
the case with the hwasong 5 6 and 7
missiles some of which have even been
exported to countries such as Iran
the problem is that scud missile
technology has limitations so if the
North Koreans wanted more powerful
missiles with longer range they needed
more efficient and rugged engines
capable of functioning at extreme
altitudes and freezing temperatures
therefore in 1999 the communist country
officially established the so-called
strategic forces of the Korean People's
Army and since then the ballistic
missile has taken a 180 degree turn
[Music]
since the late 1990s and early 2000s
Pyongyang has devoted all of its efforts
to creating a new family of missiles
with indigenous technology with more
efficient engines and greater thrust a
new family that has resulted in a
catalog with five types of missiles one
for each occasion submarine launched
short-range medium range intermediate
range and the dreaded InterContinental
missiles in theory this program has put
the communist country on a par with the
major military powers in terms of
ballistic capabilities and strategic
weapons eventually capable of delivering
nuclear warheads thousands of miles away
and along with missiles North Korea is
known so far to have succeeded in
building nuclear weapons of between 15
and 20 kilotons similar to those that
destroyed Hiroshima and Nagasaki in
1945. in the nuclear weapons industry
this is equivalent to something like a
1950s car but remember we're talking
about nuclear weapons as long as they go
they can do more than enough damage one
thing the North Koreans are still
believed not to have achieved is to
miniaturize these weapons in order to be
able to deliver them with the missiles
we have discussed because basically the
nuclear program and the ballistic
program are one and the same having said
that the next step is to know exactly
how this program is structured
well the fact is that this new strategic
force is classified distributed and
organized according to the objective in
this way leaving aside the scud-type
missiles and focusing only on the most
modern and Indigenous technology
missiles we could make the following
classification on the one hand North
Korea has a new missile capable of
attacking with relative Precision at any
point in South Korea we're talking about
the kn-23 missile
the kn23 is a solid fuel missile that
has been tested several times since
2019. it could be launched from trains
trucks or even submarines and together
with these missiles you see on the
screen this would be the third type of
missile that North Korea could launch
from a submarine it is a proven range of
430 kilometers or 267 miles and it is
believed that launched with a depressed
trajectory that is with a flatter launch
less payload and lower altitude he could
evade many of the anti-missile defense
systems such as the American thard
surprising isn't it well that's just the
beginning the next two steps in the
range the medium and intermediate range
missiles are where North Korea has put
special efforts over the last decade why
well it's simple because medium and
intermediate range missiles are the
missiles that allow Pyongyang to keep
within range of Japan and Guam two
places where the United States is
permanently stationed some of its most
advanced strategic weapons and believe
me when I say that from a strategic
point of view pyongyang's deterrent
power of having missiles capable of
reaching these places is more than
remarkable
we're talking about missiles such as the
musudan and the Hua song 12 which are
estimated to have a range of up to four
thousand and 4500 kilometers
respectively to put this into
perspective the island of Guam is less
than 3500 kilometers away from the
communist country as the crow flies in
both cases these missiles are prepared
to carry nuclear warheads and if North
Korea succeeds in miniaturizing its
nuclear weapons to the point of being
able to deliver them on such missiles
this would mean the North Korean nuclear
strike against U.S bases would be a real
possibility
[Music]
however although these missiles are two
of the means of attack that most concern
the United States because of the targets
they could reach the truth is that if we
read the Western press we will quickly
see that the ones that are really
concerning are another group entirely of
course I'm referring to InterContinental
missiles these missiles are the ones
that could take this whole issue to the
next level evidently because we're
talking about missiles with nuclear
payloads that could reach both Europe
and their continental United States
itself
all right
we are especially talking about two key
missiles the hwasong 14 and the hwasong
15 and take note because South Korean
intelligence considers the former to be
fully operational that is ready for use
it is a two-stage missile that promises
strike ranges of up to 10 400 kilometers
enough to hit the west coast of the
United States on the other hand the
hwasong 15 is a kind of evolution of the
previous model that is still under
development and has only been tested
once so it is suspected that we could
see Ballistic tests of this missile in
the near future the Communist Regime
wants this missile also to Stage to be
able to strike almost anywhere in the
world with a range of up to 13 000
kilometers that's over 8 000 miles
but not only that other missiles like
the new Hua song 17 also promised to be
one of the key pieces of the ballistic
missile program in the future however
this one is still in a fairly early
stage of its development now by now you
may be wondering but let's see how on
Earth can the North Koreans test the
range of these InterContinental missiles
when the country is so small well
actually that's a good question because
North Korea has an exclusive economic
zone that extends at most up to some 1
000 kilometers or 620 miles from its
farthest Coast but of course we're
talking about North Korea it's not as if
they're too concerned about the minutia
of what some people call international
law the fact is that the missiles fall
within Japan's exclusive economic zone
is something that Pyongyang doesn't
really care about so problem solved
[Music]
in any case in order not to provoke more
outrage than necessary what they usually
do is to test the missiles upside down
wait what do you mean upside down yeah
you heard right upside down what they do
is launch the missiles High instead of
long and then with complex calculations
they obtain what the range of the
missile would have been had it been
launched on a normal ballistic
trajectory of attack take a look at this
infographic what you see is the
trajectory of missiles in three
ballistic tests conducted in July and
November 2017. the latter corresponding
to the Hua song 15 missile as you can
see what the North Koreans do is launch
InterContinental missiles to extremely
high altitudes of up to 4 500 kilometers
high that's
2765 miles yes they launched the
missiles into the exosphere and after
re-entering the dense atmosphere they
fall into the sea so this is not a bluff
North Korea has proven missiles capable
of reaching U.S territory and that is of
particular concern if in the end as
we've already told you the North Koreans
managed to miniaturize and mount nuclear
warheads on these missiles so then the
question becomes how on Earth can this
situation be avoided could the North
Korean nuclear and Ballistic program be
stopped at this point well this is
something that we will talk about in a
future video here on visualpolitik the
questions are now over to you what
actions would you take to avert this
danger how do you think the North Korean
problem should be handled more
importantly do you really believe that
all this offensive power poses a real
risk leave us your comments below and
let's open a debate and now if you found
this video interesting please like And
subscribe to visualpolitik if you
haven't already done so as always thank
you very much for watching all the best
see you next time
[Music]